While there are certainly exceptions, as we’ll
get into shortly, according to the majority
of firsthand accounts from people who’ve
been shot we could find, having a hunk of
searing hot metal traveling around Mach 1
tear through part of your body doesn’t really
hurt much… at first.
For example, consider this account from one
Deborah Cotton who was struck by a bullet
during a Mother’s Day parade in 2013- “When
the bullet hit me, surprisingly it didn’t
hurt at all.
Not one bit, which shocked me.
I remember thinking, ‘That felt like someone
just chucked a small pebble at me.’”
In Deborah’s case, the bullet hit her in
the side around her hip and traveled up, finally
stopping around her rib cage on her left side.
She went on to have 36 surgeries, losing her
colon, gallbladder, one kidney, part of her
pancreas, two-thirds of her stomach, and the
duodenum, which, we’re not going to lie,
we had to look up.
Turns out that’s the initial bit of small
intestine directly connected to the stomach.
**The More You Know**
Interestingly, despite the severe damage to
her body, which nearly cost her her life later
at the hospital, she states,
After about 90 seconds passed, I realized,
‘Hmm…
I may not be dying after all.
I wonder if…
God forbid, am I paralyzed?’
I wiggled my toes, then my ankles; it was
all good.
So I wasn’t dying, and I wasn’t paralyzed…
There still was no sharp or shooting pain,
nothing like what you think you’ll feel
when a metal object rips through your body…
I was later told that the 9mm used in the
shooting accounted for the lack of initial
pain: The bullets were the kind that stay
intact, rather than the kind that explode
into flesh-tearing shrapnel.
If you suspect Deborah Cotton might just be
a bit of a badass to shrug off having her
insides eviscerated, consider this account
from one Ryan Jarcy, a guy who was attempting
to dial 911 to report he’d just been robbed
only to have his shotgun slip from his hand
as he was dialing the number.
When he reflexively attempted to grab it,
he accidentally pulled the trigger, shooting
himself in the leg, more or less making it
look like, to quote him, “a pile of Alpo
dog food smushed up against what used to be
just below my knee”.
He goes on:
My brain didn’t actually register what had
happened until a few seconds later.
My shin bone was sticking out about 2 to 3
inches from the ragged end of my stump, but
I felt nothing, nor did I notice it…
I attempted to stand, and then felt it.
I yelped in pain, fell flat on my face, and
made the foolish decision to try standing
up once more.
The entire weight of my body was now on that
bone.
And that bone, weakened by 96 tiny lead pellets
traveling at twice the speed of sound, didn’t
hold up very long.
It snapped like a piece of blood-soaked chalk,
jamming the shards into my newly opened calf
muscle and feeling, oh, let’s go with “uncomfortable”.
(Incidentally, to add insult to life threatening
injury, Mr. Jarcy notes that all of this occurred
a mere 12 hours after he’d been removed
from his parent’s health insurance coverage
and he had not gotten any of his own yet,
with the whole thing, including amputation
of his leg, costing him a little over $60,000.)
So, for many, there is little pain at first.
But what about other sensations?
While various people report everything from
a bee-sting sensation to getting hit with
a baseball bat, minus the pain, one nearly
universal report is of extreme and persistent
burning sensation in the initial aftermath,
as redditor Tia_Jamon states:
I’m not one of those, ‘I didn’t even
realize I was shot’ people, though I can
definitely understand where they’re coming
from.
The very first thing I felt can only be described
as a sudden impact of no sensation.
I felt numbness wash over the area.
If I had not realized I was about to be shot
shortly before I was, I could see how I could
have easily have been too distracted to notice
this immediate response.
That feeling then gave way to a horrible burning
sensation.
It’s a very ‘hot’ pain.
It feels the way a very flushed face or a
blister feels, but intense and painful.”
Going back to Deborah Cotton she corroborates
this, stating, “As I continued to take inventory
of my body and soul, that burning sensation
in my stomach where the bullet traveled began
to take over my focus.”
Yet another account relates, “It’s a bit
of [a] burning sensation mainly…
Best way I can describe it is that it feels
like being continuously poked as if someone
is holding multiple sharp pricks to you and
pushing in, but not stabbing.
”
From there the similarities in accounts of
what it’s like to get shot vary much more
significantly, depending on location of injury.
For some, pain comes quickly after the initial
shock wears of, sometimes extremely quickly.
For example, in the case of a lawyer who got
shot in the knee, he reported almost no blood,
but “for me at least, the ‘it doesn’t
hurt because of the shock’ part lasted about
2 seconds.
Then, immense pain that I can’t even begin
to compare to anything else.
By the time I got some morphine, I was drenched
in sweat and writhing uncontrollably from
the pain, and I normally have a high pain
tolerance.”
Others simply report waves of general achenes
growing to an extreme level, while in a minority
of cases, some don’t note much of any real
pain after.
As one man shot in the calf by a .22 jokes,
“Honestly, it didn’t hurt that bad.
Hopefully, being shot by a smaller caliber
has helped me build my immunity up towards
larger bullets.”
One side note here is what getting shot in
the head feels like.
It turns out plenty of people actually survive
this type of wound, with those who are still
quite cognoscente of the incident universally
reporting extreme headache like symptoms.
For example, one Michael Moylan actually didn’t
even know he’d been shot.
Turns out his wife had “accidentally”
shot him in the head while he slept…
The result was simply him waking up and noting
he had a severe headache and asking his wife,
April, to drive him to the hospital, which
she did.
It was only after a nurse looked him over
that she informed him he’d been shot in
the head, at which point April bolted…
What’s more interesting than the headache
symptoms, though, is something else universally
reported in the handful of accounts of head
shot survivors we reviewed.
They all report an accompanying ringing.
As Gary Melius, who was shot in the head and
also likewise didn’t realize what had happened
until at the hospital, states “there was
a ringing inside of my head.
It was a noise that I’ll never forget.
Never heard it before, and never heard it
since.
It was like being in a can, I guess.
Just so loud.”
Joab Hodge further states of his experience
getting shot in the head, “their is this
very loud buzzing, almost a sort of ringing
type sound as to when it happens.
Surprisingly it is very loud, like two bees
inside of your ears, but sounds more like
how your ears would normally ring, just uncomfortably
loud.
The initial ‘ping’ as I call it, can be
heard before the ringing commences, like someone
hitting metal on metal, but it’s high-pitched.
After that, very loud and scary ringing commences,
but no pain is registered at that moment.”
As for the long term aftermath of getting
shot in general, this varies considerably,
again based on the extent and location of
the damage, though victims often reported
the recovery and rehab is worse than the initial
pain of getting shot.
Going back to the case of the aforementioned
lawyer shot in the knee, he states, “What
the movies seem to miss most though is the
long term recovery.
It was months of continuous pain afterward.
Oxy barely took the edge off.”
More than potential long term chronic pain
and the like, perhaps unsurprisingly for people
who endured such physical trauma and in many
cases near loss of life, the psychological
side of being shot is also occasionally noted
as being something else that makes the whole
experience awful.
As stated by Deborah Cotton,
The impact of the shooting on my mental health,
though, showed up in surprising ways.
I endured bouts of PTSD during the first few
months after the shooting.
Once home, I began counseling sessions with
two psychologists, both PTSD experts.
For a while, I was terrified of being in a
car going over 35mph, and I’m not exactly
sure why, since driving doesn’t seem to
have anything in common with guns…but eventually
the fear faded away.
So there you have it, while specific accounts
of what it’s like to be shot vary wildly,
in the general case it would seem you can
expect little in the way of initial pain,
or even much sense that you may have just
been mortally wounded, followed by an onset
of extreme burning, followed by some measure
of general pain, followed by chronic pain
throughout recovery and maybe beyond, and
potentially a little side of psychological
trauma just for fun.
That is, if you simply don’t die in the
first place.
Good times…